well let me know whenever you're ready
alright everybody what's going on bleh
here I'm actually in our offices in a
back hallway on the Warner Brothers lot
right next to stage 15 where we're gonna
film our show and I thought I'd show you
guys something really cool these the
stage is very old and so because it's
old it's got rafters there's nothing
like going up in some rafters let's do
it it's extremely old and wooden and
creaky and scary how's this shot is this
a good shot it's a good shot that's
right you can see it's totally crazy
being up here because we're hundreds of
feet above the floor of the studio you
can take a look down there and check it
out it's a you know it's probably only a
couple hundred feet but it feels like a
couple thousand feet I'm not scared of
heights but I am scared of death so it's
still pretty freaky these are the air
conditioning units here that are gonna
cool the studio audience because we'll
be laughing so hard at our hilarious
comedy there's guys working hanging
lights for our new show yeah it's hot up
here I sweat a lot anyway but it's hot
up here man
[Music]
people have all signed people who've
worked here we've all signed these
different beams which I thought was
pretty awesome so I thought I would sign
a beam myself I mean we're gonna be
working here now so makes sense so I
brought a little marker right here so
here we go
there you go right there
pretty great right oh forget what saying
: what do you want dude he's cute
I'm sorry I'll see you guys later
[Music]